hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast inflation is
high interest rates are rising borrowing
is at record levels so can Jeremy Hunt
lift our Spirits about what he calls
misplaced Gloom when he outlines the
state of the UK economy this morning
we'll be hearing from experts throughout
the program and we'll take that speech
live just after nine plus could the UK's
Premier Rail Project really end at a
rail yard in West London instead of the
showpiece Houston Station we'll be
reporting live it's Friday the 27th of
January
boom not Gloom the chancellor will look
ahead to the prospects for the UK
economy in a major speech this morning
after finally receiving pledges of
modern battle tanks from Western
Partners Ukraine is now asking for
fighter jets As It prepares for new
offensives with Russia
help the NHS Sky News gets VIP backing
as it launches a year-long campaign
looking at the state of the Health
Service
we have a caller now who's been
compelled to call us this afternoon
after watching from his home in
Hertfordshire it is so Rod Stewart
it's freezing the temperatures in China
plunged to record lows as climate
concerns increase
uncovering history the promise of
treasures hidden for hundreds of years
from a 17th century warship buried off
the coast of Sussex
in the sport we'll hear from managers
ahead of the FA Cup fourth round tie
between Manchester City and Arsenal
foreign
[Music]
Chic the Canadian brown bear who loved
the wildlife camera so much he turned up
again and again
and again
[Music]
hello a very good morning to you the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt will set out his
plan for long-term Prosperity today
against the background of warnings about
the state of the economy Mr Hunt will
say that Britain is ready to take
advantage of brexit freedoms but the
figures show the country is struggling
for growth
well the current rate of inflation is
10.5 percent interest rates are
currently at 3.5 percent but they're
expected to rise to at least four
percent next month and government
borrowing hits a new high in December of
27.4 billion pounds that's the highest
since records began
back in 1993
well let's bring in our political
correspondent Rob Powell now so Jeremy
Hunt making the case for being
optimistic about the economy but that's
quite tough isn't it given some of the
forecasts around yeah Jeremy Hunt trying
to set a more chipper tone I think today
laying out what he says will be the
long-term plan for prosperity for
economic growth and very much saying
that this is based on some of the
freedoms the country has after brexit
he'll also talk about the attitude of
what he'll say is declinism and set out
a case for optimism and he'll say some
of the stats that are used to describe
economic growth in the last 10 years
don't reflect the full picture the one
he is pointing to is GDP growth economic
growth since 2010 saying that
um we've outdone countries like France
Japan and Italy okay but I think there's
a sense here that Jeremy Hunt might be
doing and engaging with what he is
accusing others of doing in terms of
cherry picking statistics because once
you strip out things like population
growth and look more at productivity how
efficient workers and processes and the
economy is actually things look
decidedly less Rosy and I think that's
reflected probably in in the measure
that will impact how most people feel
the country has been doing over the last
10 years living standards it was only
back in Autumn the office of budget
responsibility that provide the
independent forecasts for government
um said that a drop in household
spending power will wipe out the last
eight years of growth effectively and
when you look at think tanks like the
institute for fiscal studies that study
this day in day out they point to things
like median real wages and so they
they're really at the same place they
were back at the early 2010s so for a
lot of people I don't think it will feel
like the economy is doing well over the
last decade and that's why I think a lot
of this is driven by politics maybe
rather than economics it's driven by a
necessity to try and sound a bit more
optimistic and maybe show a bit of leg
to Tory back benches who want more of a
focus on growth and less of a sense that
the government is just firefighting well
yes an interesting say it's more about
politics the government desperately
trying to to bring out some good news
aren't they because they've got so many
pressures on members of their cabinet
yeah and a lot of a lot of politics
around at the moment for the
conservative party Nadeem zahar with
Tori Barty chairman under investigation
at the moment by the prime minister's
ethics
um advisor confirmation yesterday that
he will allow hmrc the tax man to share
tax records as part of that
investigation with the ethics advisor
and yesterday interested me as well of
course we had the boss of hmrc appearing
in a select committee not talking
specifically about Nadeem zahawi but
saying you don't just get innocent
penalties you don't get penalties issued
for innocent errors suggesting there
might have been something more to this I
think Rishi sunak has boxed himself into
a position now that he won't necessarily
do anything until that report comes back
so unless Nadeem zahari decides he's
gonna go then I think that's going to be
the next big moment when this report
comes out and I find it hard to see if
that report comes back and says he has
broken the ministerial code how he'll be
able to stay I think given the the
emphasis Rishi sunak has placed on
integrity and countability I think if
he's found to have broken the rules
he'll probably be sacked yeah and still
no timeline on when that report will
come out it might be quite soon might be
quite soon watch this space Rob at the
moment thanks very much indeed
um and do stay with us here on Sky news
this morning because we will have full
coverage of the chancellor of speech
that's due to start at about 20 past
nine
now the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has said the latest Russian
attacks back up their case for more
weapons from the West at least 11 people
died in missile strikes but now
expectations are growing that both sides
are preparing for new offensives
so let's bring in our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes who joins
us from Kiev so a heavy night and day of
strikes Deborah there in Ukraine
yes yesterday we woke up to the the
sound of um of sirens there was
um missile strikes that were targeted
towards this country a day after uh
Ukraine finally received those pledges
from Germany and the U.S following the
UK pledge to send main battle tanks to
Ukraine as this country prepares yet
again for what many believe is going to
be a large offensive operations by the
spring it's both Russia and Ukraine
moving now into this next phase of of
the war a war which will Mark its
one-year anniversary in terms of when
the full-scale invasion was launched and
both sides knowing that they need to
re-arm they need to re-equip and they
need to be ready to try to shift these
entrenched lines that have become pretty
static over the winter even though the
fighting hasn't stopped it's been
relentlessly bloody and that's why the
president didn't when he spoke to Kay
Burley during an interview earlier in
the week was saying he's thankful very
thankful to Germany to the U.S for
saying that they're going to send tanks
but the critical thing is volume and
also speed it's no point these tanks
coming in after the offensives have
started the UK yesterday said that they
hope that their 14 Challenger 2 main
battle tanks will have arrived in this
country by the end of March but that
still isn't going to be enough Ukraine
wants hundreds of Tanks about 150 have
been committed but for example the
Americans say that it's going to take
many many months until their tanks
arrive Deborah thanks very much indeed
now it's reported this morning that the
UK's Landmark hs2 rail line might end at
a station in West London rather than the
central London Houston Station terminus
well the Sun newspaper reports that
soaring inflation has meant that the
High-Speed Rail Project may not run to
Houston until 2038 or a central London
destination could be scrapped completely
with trains instead stopping at a new
Hub at Old Oak common in the suburbs of
West London
well joining me now is our correspondent
Matthew Thompson who's at London's
yeaston station and at the government
responding to these reports at all
Matthew
responding in a manner of speaking yes I
mean only in so far as to refuse to deny
that the report is true instead a
government spokesman said that the
government remained committed to
delivering hs2 to Manchester as
confirmed in the awesome statement but
nothing said about these extraordinary
new plans to to Move It from Central
London here at Houston to a hub at
although common in West London and let's
remember why exactly that would be so
extraordinary because hs2 was designed
in large part to provide quick and
Speedy and direct access between London
and the Midlands and the north of
England so to move its Terminus in
London to somewhere way in the west and
commuters and passengers would then have
to get the Elizabeth line from although
common into the center of London if
that's where they were coming it rather
fatally undermines the entire point of
the Enterprise the reason for this that
the sun reports is soaring inflation
soaring construction costs which mean
that the plans as currently in place are
no longer viable may need to be changed
they're talking about either delaying
its arrival in Houston until 2038
scrapping it all together possibly a two
to five year delay to the entire project
and and none of those things being
denied explicitly by the government this
morning they are saying of course as I
say that the plans remain to send it to
Manchester but plans to send it to Leeds
have already been scrapped so it's
possible if not even likely given the
cost pressures and financial situation
facing the project that more tough
decisions will need to be made but what
I think is conspicuous by its absence
this morning is the fact that the
government is not denying these reports
in the sun about moving its terminals
from Central London which was always
intended to be to somewhere way in the
west that many commuters will have to
look up on a map
Matthew thank you be interesting to see
where that one goes
now also this morning medical staff are
battling to keep up with demand as
senior NHS figures claim the service is
under greater pressure now than at any
time in its history what Sky News is
launching a year-long project with
analysis from two of the UK's leading
Health think tanks the king's fund and
the health Foundation to find ways of
tackling the crisis that's gripping the
Health Service well over the last week
ambulance weights outside a e have
fallen with just over 10 000 hours lost
to delays outside hospitals compared to
almost 14 000 the week before
there were record wait times between
Christmas and New Year with 227 000
hours lost due to longer patient
Handover delays that's double that of
December 2021.
delays in ambulance staff handing over
patients to a e meant as many as 57 000
patients experienced potential harm last
month
and more than 13 500 hospital beds in
England last week were filled with
people who were fit to leave although
the number is down on recent record
levels Tom Cheshire reports
Michael and Paul live in South Yorkshire
with a 16 year old twin Sons Levi and
Lucas they suffer from various
disabilities last summer Levi had a
seizure and fell hitting his head on a
door well what I find very difficult is
the fact that they left a child with
severe autism and all his disabilities
just sat there with me waiting to be
seen for a very long time Paul and
Michael took part in a Sky News debate
on the future of the NHS held at
University Hospital Coventry where
people shared their stories we can't
physically carry them now if they have a
seizure the nearly 17. but you're having
to manage the children themselves and
it's so complex and a lot of doctors
listening to this in pediatric will
understand that it's so complex and it
can be a case of life and life and death
there are delays at every stage of the
journey including from ambulance to a e
this is what the data tells us for
December last year if four ambulances
turned up to accident an emergency two
of them had to wait more than 30 minutes
to transfer patients 25 of ambulances
one in four had to wait more than an
hour and once patients are in accident
in emergency there's yet another wait in
December one in three people across all
NES had to wait more than four hours to
be assessed that's way up on 2019 and
far far above that Target of five
percent each one of those data points is
someone's story someone's life like
Zahir Ahmed his nephew died after
waiting hours for treatment for
tonsillitis today his infection spreaded
to his chest he spread it to his lungs
caused him pneumonia and then use of
Yusuf died so we do we do we do think
that if he did get his antibiotics when
he needed them the IV antibiotics user
would have been alive today the stories
are heartbreaking the numbers deeply
alarming Tom Cheshire Sky News
special skinnies program inviting people
to share their experiences about the NHS
received one unexpected call from a very
high profile viewer
so Rod Stewart good to hear from you
this afternoon thank you so much for
calling in what made you pick up the
phone uh Sarah hi I've been watching the
program all day this is ridiculous you
know and I I would like to pay 10 by 10
or 20 scans I don't know how we're going
to work this out and hopefully some
other people will follow because it
seems ridiculous at this particular
scanning Clinic was empty and there are
people dying because they cannot get
scans now listen to me I don't need the
publicity
um I you know I just want to do some
good things
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
morning's Sky News Daily podcast and
would you be willing to pay to see your
GP that's the question that Neil
Patterson is posing and he hears from a
group of GPS on the challenges of
increased Demand on their services and
you could subscribe to the Daily
wherever you get your podcasts
let's take a look now what's making the
front pages of this morning's papers and
the mirror leads with Rod Stewart's
critique of the government over the
crisis in the NHS which he made right
here on Sky News of course it's headline
We are failing
the telegraph also covers that story on
their front page but their main story is
the controversial transgender law in
Scotland
The Daily Mail previews the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt's plans for economic growth
the guardian says there's anger over the
government's u-turn on implementing
Windrush inquiry recommendations
and the times understands that the
government intends to loosen
restrictions on working hours for
foreign students in a bid to boost the
economy
so let's come here on the show ahead of
the chancellor speech I'm going to be
speaking to former economics advisor to
Theresa May and Senior fellow at The
Institute for government Giles wills and
then at half of seven I'll be joined by
a defense policy expert Tony Lawrence to
discuss whether the donations of Tanks
to Ukraine will be enough to push Russia
back
and then join me at 7 45 as a professor
of Law and transitional Justice Kieran
McAvoy to discuss the Northern Ireland
Legacy bill and the controversies
surrounding it
but right now let's take a look at some
of the day's other headlines and the US
is bracing for the release of body cam
footage of the violent beating of Tyree
Nichols five police officers have been
charged with murder for the death of the
29 year old he died in hospital after
what his family has described as a
Savage beating following a traffic stop
and a confrontation with Memphis Police
today marks Holocaust Memorial Day which
remembers the genocide of six million
Jews during World War II it's the 78th
anniversary of the liberation of the
former Nazi concentration and death
camps Auschwitz birkenau comedian David
bediel says the day highlights modern
day anti-semitism
I do think people are more aware which
is the most important thing of
anti-Semitism and how it can spiral into
something extraordinarily violent I
think people are more aware of that than
they were and they hold it in their
minds more and part of that is without
doubt Holocaust Memorial Day
around 85 Fighters tackled a church fire
in North London overnight the grade two
Victorian church was destroyed by The
Blaze London fire brigade used a 64
meter ladder the tallest in Europe to
get water onto the building
Israel has carried out airstrikes in
Gaza after Palestinian militants fired
two rockets towards Southern Israel the
cross-border fire came after an Israeli
raid in the occupied West Bank yesterday
that led to the largest single death
toll in years of fighting
women from Caribbean and African
backgrounds can be twice as likely to
receive a late-stage cancer diagnosis
than white British women analysis by
cancer research UK found that ethnicity
is a significant factor in the stage of
diagnosis for women with a range of
different cancers
I mean I had you know dark area on my
breast which
um now knowing that kind of how breast
cancer presents was a clear sign that
you know there was something very wrong
with my breast which wasn't picked up by
um the nurse that did my exam when I
first initially
um found the lump in 2016.
now the chance for Jeremy Hunt will make
a major speech today in which is
expected to pledge to boost growth and
productivity there's unlikely to be any
promise of tax cuts however well senior
fellow at The Institute for government
and former economic advisor to Theresa
May Giles Wills joins me now a very good
morning to you Jazz Wells thanks so much
for talking to us and so this is Jeremy
Hunt's first major speech of Chancellor
and comes just weeks ahead of the budget
so how important a speech is it and what
do you think he's likely to say look I
think it's very important for him
personally because he's actually done a
good job as Chancellor given that he had
one job when he came in in October which
was to write the government's finances
to stop the spiral that seemed to be
hitting both the government and the
conservative party and pushing mortgage
rates up to eye watering levels he's
done that and he's done that by
announcing that things are going to be
really really difficult by recognizing
it and by taking some measures though
not all of them necessary to to write it
however he's now a very sort of negative
Chancellor from that point of view and
the conservatives are trading 20 25
points in the polls and need to have a
positive Vision to present to the people
to say look stick with us I know things
have been really rubbish but we've got
some kind of
glorious vision for the future that
means you can look forward to life under
a conservative government which is an
incredibly tall order well yeah exactly
we are told that he is going to set out
that
Ace for Optimum the economy but how hard
a cell is that when just this week we
got reports that the obr the
government's official economic
forecaster is likely to revise down its
predictions for growth and they weren't
that great in the first place it's
incredibly difficult for several reasons
one that that downgrade is coming and
it's a kind of reasonable downgrade
because the obr has noticed that year
after year after year it continuously
forecasts that we will be becoming more
productive in a few years time and then
it doesn't happen and it sounds like
they're saying okay let's accept that
we're not going to and see what the
books look like then number two anything
he announces and he's got some great
sounding plans around sort of leveling
up agenda devolving choosing some
sectors that the UK is really good at
anything he does announce he might have
some plans out by the end of the year
some legislational money by the year
afterwards and the effects hit the
economy two or three years after that so
the economy won't grow because it gives
an absolutely brilliant speech today
um it takes a long time for it all to
come in and finally we've still got an
awful lot of trouble coming in 2023
we've got a higher entry interest rates
the the effects of the Ukraine war was
still hitting business confidence we've
got the expiry of a really generous tax
break that his predecessor as Chancellor
Rishi sunak brought in this thing called
the super deduction he needs to come up
with some kind of an alternative to that
or otherwise companies will be put off
from investing so he's got a real wall
to climb before he can ever get people
to start thinking positively
well yes and when inflation is high
interest rates are still rising and
people are dealing with the worst cost
of living crisis for a generation how
much can he say to make people feel more
optimistic he talks about the dangers of
being too Gloom and too Doom and Gloom
and talks about declinism but but can he
talk people into feeling better about
the economy well if only is so simple if
we all believed it sort of a Tinkerbell
theory if we just believed it enough
then the economy would necessarily grow
obviously it's better to be optimistic
than pessimistic he wants the people
around him and his party in particular
to believe so that they'll push through
the plans take some of the tough
political decisions around things like
planning for example or reforming the
tax system but belief on its own doesn't
do it mostly you reform economies by
taking five or ten years of really tough
decisions and Ordinary People is not
just about an optimistic speech they
want to see something coming up in the
budget amounts the 15th to make and
think actually the next few months might
be a little better than the last few
months and mostly that's in the lap of
the Gods not something that Jeremy Hunt
can himself control things like lower
energy prices that mostly come from
forces outside of his control
unfortunately well yes and yet there'll
be some in his own party that will say
actually you can give us something in
the next budget you can give us lower
taxes and that would boost growth what
what might he say on that well it
wouldn't boost growth because we learned
last Autumn that putting money into the
economy as inflation is still really
high simply forces the bank of England
to raise rates more or the markets to
panic and put up rates that way too it's
it's too great a risk it's only a few
months ago that the UK was being treated
like a developing World economy for
cutting taxes without doing the maths
and as it is he's only just brought the
fiscal deficit projections under control
and he doesn't even have all of the
spending cuts that he needs to achieve
that fully worked out so adding tax cuts
to that and we might be back in the
situation we were in last Autumn so he's
right to resist those siren voices from
his own party I'm afraid
and he will talk up the UK economy
compared to other countries he'll say
that it's grown faster since 2010 than
France Japan and Italy for example
um and since the brexit referendum we've
grown about the same rate as Germany is
it fair to say that we compare well with
our our competitors you know what the
fundamentals of the UK economy apart
from I I do have to mention brexit
because cutting yourself off from such a
big Market isn't good for your economy
but the fundamentals have always been
great this is why normally every decade
at least since Margaret Thatcher's
reforms we've expected to grow faster
and it's only 15 years ago that our own
productivity started really lagging so
the optimistic case to say is look the
laws of this country are fine the tax
rate isn't too high we don't pay that
much we have well-educated people some
really great Industries like life
sciences like Financial Services like
Advanced manufacturing the fundamentals
are there we've just had to be hit by a
number of unnecessary errors like too
Harsha bread exit the covid pandemic is
still working through and Underneath It
All We're a great developing country
he's right to say that it's just it
takes a long time for it to be felt by
people and it means not making these
repeated errors again giving the
business world five years of certainty
to work with
you mentioned brexit he's likely to say
that um the brexit
freedoms that brexit gives the UK are
going to be the the power behind the
growth that we'll get
yes that's something optimistic I would
say I mean mostly when you talk to
business what they want is the kind of
certainty and uniformity across the
large markets on which they trade so
they don't want us to have entirely
different standards for our manufactured
products or our chemicals here than they
have in Europe so they don't have to
have two sets of compliance going on
they want the kind of um they don't want
to be thinking about regulation
obviously if there are really poor
regulations that we can improve he
should be going after that and some of
the advanced sectors he's looking at
might well be areas of potential for us
but I wouldn't say that's going to be
the major cause of both it's certainly
something that he ought to be working on
but there's a lot of other ways of
boosting sectors than simply slashing
red tape providing a long-term
predictable strategy around them is
normally the best way to do it okay
Charles Wills are very interesting to
get your take on things former economics
advisors Theresa May thanks very much
indeed
so I do say we're here with us on Sky
news this morning because we'll have
full coverage of the Chancellor's speech
from 20 past nine this morning
now researchers have managed to identify
a whale stranded on the Pembroke Coast
more than a decade ago so let's take a
look at it it's the first short-finned
pilot whale to be found in British
Waters and the species are normally more
typical in warmer more tropical waters
and its Discovery adds to Growing
evidence of a trend of marine life being
affected by climate change
sort of taking it now what the weather's
up to
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look mainly fine
with daytime temperatures mostly around
average it's a largely dry and frosty
start with freezing fog patches in the
west especially for Ireland and Northern
Ireland well that fog will be slow to
lift during the morning with travel
disruption possible but there will be
sunny spells elsewhere it'll stay mainly
dry but the odd shower will affect
England's East Coast temperatures will
be like yesterday's but the chilly wind
will become confined to the southeast
and increasing cloud in the northwest of
the afternoon will bring Wind and Rain
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up in just a moment on Skinny's
breakfast I'll be joined by a defense
policy expert Tony Lawrence to discuss
whether the donations of Tanks to
Ukraine will be enough to push Russia
back
[Music]
welcome back to Sky News breakfast our
top stories here this morning boom not
Gloom the chancellor will look ahead to
the prospects for the UK economy in a
major speech later this morning
with more deaths from Russian drone
strikes at Ukraine's president zielinski
calls on the west to increase the supply
of weapons to his country
reports suggests that the hs2 high-speed
rail line could be scaled back due to
spiraling costs
so the danger of Russian air attacks in
Ukraine remains high today after Russian
missiles and drones killed at least 11
people yesterday however more tanks will
come eventually from Candor Poland
Britain Finland and Norway so what
difference could they make well joining
me now is Tony Lawrence who's head of
defense policy and strategy program at
the International Center for defense and
security a very good morning to you Tony
Lawrence so what difference will these
pledges I mean particularly from the U.S
and Germany on tanks make to the war in
Ukraine do you think oh good morning and
thank you for the invitation to join you
uh so if um if Ukraine is to achieve its
objectives in the war in in terms of
restoring its territorial Integrity uh
the war needs to start moving again and
uh tanks in combination with with other
donations that western states have made
in in recent months so uh armored
fighting Vehicles artillery pieces and
so on and so forth will give it much
more options in in starting the war
moving again and moving in directions
that are favorable to it
in an interview with um this guy's Cape
early just a few days ago said he was
very thankful for the tanks but he did
warn that the number of the timing was
critical are there enough when Ukrainian
officials say they need at least 300
tanks
well uh as ever
um Western supporters sort of stepped up
and stepped over the thresholds it's
imposed in itself over over the course
of the war so the fact that we've now
stepped over this this
um threshold of supplying tanks I think
it's an important development and I
think it will open the door to providing
more as the weeks and months go on but
yes clearly Ukraine wants more than the
western states are willing to deliver at
the moment
well yes and you say it stepped over a
threshold could it prompt a different
response from Russia
while the evidence so far has been that
that's not the case I mean this is not
the first threshold that we've stepped
over
um back at the start of the wall we were
supplying only small handheld large
defensive items we then started Supply
and water back manufactured heavier
equipment and then on to Western
designer manufactured to artillery
pieces air defense and so on and so
forth and each time Russia hasn't
responded any sort of practical
practical way to that I mean there's
been lots of flustering complaint of
course but um it has not actually any
had any effect on the ground
well yes and you say that Ukraine's
allies have stepped up their supply of
weapons what next then president
zelenski is again calling on the west to
increase its supply of weapons following
more airstrikes in the last 24 hours
what else could the International
Community give do you think
yeah I think it's important to stress I
mean that the coverage of the tank
debate has been been very extensive and
uh it's important to avoid the
impression that this is somehow a silver
bulletin this is the end of the federal
Western support for for Ukraine's
efforts
um certainly in the coming months
there'll be a need for a lot more of the
same so you know more armored vehicles
more tanks more ammunition in particular
one of the big surprises of this war has
been just the rate of ammunition use and
both sides are suffering from from that
um so a lot more of the same but
possibly also further items and
president zielinski of course is
interested in getting fighter jets
also long range long-range missile
artillery so we're by no means near the
end of the process
that's what he wants will he get them
uh it's it's hard to say I mean you know
we've seen that the caution of some
countries over the debate on over tanks
um those those cautions and those fears
still remain so these are discussions
that the Allies have to have amongst
themselves and uh and we'll see the
outcome when it when it comes
what are the prospects for peace
president zielinski told us that
President Putin was a nobody he said
that they don't want any any talks
Russia doesn't want any any talks in
reality how do you think this could end
it's very hard to say I mean one thing
that we again have can be certain of
from this war is is we're going to be
surprised and the unexpected will happen
but at the moment at least in in the
coming months uh I didn't see either
side being particularly interested in
pursuing peace negotiations uh both
sides have not achieved what they want
on the battlefield so I think we know
this is this is somewhat somewhere off
and in the meantime do you expect a
spring offensive from both sides
I think that's uh that's what Miss um
yes I mean as I said at the beginning
both sides need to get the war moving to
achieve their objectives and a spring
offensive or early summer offensive is
the way to do that
okay well Tony Lawrence head of defense
policy and strategy program at the
International Center for defense and
security thanks very much indeed for
your thoughts this morning
thank you very much
now earlier this week temperatures in
parts of northern China dropped to their
lowest ever with minus 53 Celsius
recorded in one city our Asia
correspondent Helen Smith has the latest
from mohi in hey long Zhang province
here she is it is genuinely quite
difficult to describe just how cold this
cold feels you think you can imagine
what temperatures of this degrees might
feel like until you actually get here
and it really is different to what you
feel that you could have imagined or
having to be incredibly careful as a
team not spending more than a few
minutes at a time outside not giving too
much skin exposed but I just want to
show you this to show you just a sense
of just how cold it is
um we're gonna just tip a cup of boiling
water into the air and just watch this
that's frozen mid-air and by the time it
hits the ground it's already big clumps
of ice that are all sort of gathering
Gathering there and look this is the
town of Moher it's known as China's
North Pole it is always cold here we are
right up in the very Northern
northernmost part of China right on the
border
um with Russian Siberia this week it has
set records minus 53 degrees which the
local meteorology Department described
as the coldest in the modern history of
China and what's causing it is this very
very cold period area of low pressure
that's been moving south
um from Siberia because some of the wind
systems that would normally keep it up
in the north there have broken down and
but it's worth saying that this extreme
cold event it is matched by an extreme
heat event that this country saw in the
summer in China in 2022 this country saw
historic heat waves historic droughts
lasting a number of months great
portions of the huge Yangtze River
completely dried up officials here
called it one of the most serious events
in China's history so that sense of
extremes of weather many people say of
course of course contribute to by
climate change
wow quite extraordinary temperatures
there now an unknown wreck off the coast
of Sussex has been identified as a 17th
century Dutch warship discovered in 2019
the Clane hollandia has been granted the
highest level of protection as it's
considered an immensely important find
Sky's Alice Porter reports
[Music]
hidden under the depths of the English
Channel for over 300 years the identity
of a mysterious shipwreck has been
finally solved
it's all thanks to a team of Maritime
archaeologists who spent four years
diving over the site
the Klein hollandia was a 17th century
Dutch warship used to defend trade
routes
the British Navy took control of the
ship in battle but it was badly damaged
and went down with men from both sides
on board it's a battle where only one
ship sinks had had four ships sunk or
ten ships sunk we would have we probably
wouldn't know which one it was but it's
it's just a bit of luck really that
actually in this one battle in the march
of 1672 just one sinks and so nailing
you know identifying that that is our
one has been easier than it could have
been
Priceless historical items have been
found by the wreck including bronze
Cannon and pieces of Italian Pottery but
not all the treasures will remain on the
seabed there's a protected wreck our aim
is to keep the material in situ on the
seabed and that's that's the best place
for it as much as possible however when
a material is particularly at risk of
being lost if it's at risk of being
washed away by the tides we will make a
decision to recover it in that case
the Klein hollandia shows a unique
glimpse into 17th century life at Sea
historians hoped to preserve it for
future Generations
Alice Porter Sky News
a former Soldier found guilty of killing
a man more than 30 years ago is due to
face a sentence hearing today David
Holden was convicted of manslaughter in
1998 the first veteran to be found
guilty of a historical offense in
Northern Ireland since the Good Friday
agreement
well dating back to 1968 Northern
Ireland was plagued by a period of
deadly violence known as the troubles it
began in the midst of centuries of
conflict predominantly between Catholic
Ireland and Protestant England and
pictures show that British troops
arriving in Belfast being met with
resistance from local groups the
violence peaked in 1972 with the Bloody
Sunday shooting of 13 unarmed Men by the
British army which was which greatly
increased tensions between Irish
nationalists towards the British
well joining me now is the professor of
Law and transitional Justice at Queen's
University Belfast here in McAvoy a very
good morning to you just how significant
a moment is the sentencing of of David
Holden and what can we expect
and well he's been convicted as you say
Anna of manslaughter normal range of
sentence for a manslaughter
um conviction could be anywhere between
two and ten years and the reality
whoever is well first of all under the
good trade agreement no one can serve
more than two years and so he definitely
won't get more than that but to be
honest there's already a technical fix
by which the government will ensure that
he doesn't do a day in jail so I don't
think anybody any of the family is
affected here would have high
expectations and that Mr Holden will do
a day in jail
um there is a way in which the
government can in effect reduce the
two-year maximum under the Good Friday
agreement to zero and most of us on this
side of the ward I would expect that's
what will happen
and meanwhile the government is pushing
through its new Northern Ireland Legacy
Bill aren't they will that mean do you
think he could be the only veteran ever
convicted
um that's very possible I mean I'm going
to use a technical legal phrase on the
bill that's being pushed through
Parliament currently it's a dog's dinner
in fact
um it's so it's it's a Billet is opposed
by all of the local political parties in
Northern Ireland I suppose by the Irish
government it's been heavily criticized
by the U.N by the country of Europe by
lots lots of stakeholders victims
churches and so forth
um and what it what this bill does is it
introduces an amnesty and it replaces uh
investigations with reviews and it means
that no family
um like the Aiden Megan ask you family
the fact that the family affected by Mr
Holden and will ever have their day in
court so needless to say it is heavily
heavily opposed it's also opposed by
Infernus Paul of the opposition parties
in Westminster and so it is possible Mr
Holden will be the last uh veteran
convicted yes and if that if if that
happens it's also possible he will be
the last person convicted or certainly
the last person
um hold before the courts because we
think it'll be quite difficult actually
to secure any prosecutions once the
spell goes 34 um
well yes and as you say a certain amount
of opposition to this bill the
government though would say that it
creates this new truth recovery body
doesn't it the independent commission
for reconciliation and information and
they have said in answer to some of the
criticisms that they are pushing forward
uh new amendments that would improve
this body's investigative powers and
also there'll be a more robust process
on the immunity from prosecution do you
think that will reassure the critics at
all no I mean I've looked at the
amendments in some details actually made
the bill worse you know and I mean it's
it's for for an English audience it's
quite a complex piece but essentially if
you think back this bill we had an
agreement here to implement mechanisms
for dealing with the past between the
local parties the British and the Irish
governments with legislation drafted
they've been a public consultation it
was all going ahead we were essentially
ready to rock with that and then Boris
Johnson's government came in and with
the same kind of cavalier disregard for
the rule of law that we saw around
brexit negotiations and his government
said no we're not doing that we're going
to introduce an amnesty this is after
years of negotiation so that the reason
this bill looks like a dog dinner is
because it comes from that same kind of
Reckless
um impulse that that drove the Johnson
Administration and Russia student X
government have kind of picked it up and
instead of just going back to the
drawing board and saying okay we had
this moment where we appeared to lose
our minds slightly as a competent
government let's get back to reality
let's let's negotiate with the Irish and
the local political parties and Northern
Ireland let's find a consensus drawing
upon the agreement we already had
instead of doing that they're pressing
ahead and that's why they're meeting the
outright opposition that they are at
Westminster and from all of the other
cage stakeholders well yes and Boris
Johnson in that 2019 Manifesto said he
wanted the government to give better
protection for military veterans from
investigations to do with the troubles
and they're you know one veterans group
that represents 200 000 army veterans as
you might imagine are supporting it they
say that the bill means that veterans
are left alone to live the last years of
their lives in relative peace without
being pursued for political reasons
yeah I mean no veteran were ever pursued
for political reasons I mean the reality
first of all it's important to say that
there's not a consensus amongst the
veterans community
um on this bill actually you know
veterans from Northern Ireland and
certainly former police officers from
Northern Ireland that I speak to have
argued strongly that as far as they're
concerned they didn't do anything wrong
so why would you need an amnesty you
know if you didn't do anything wrong why
do you need an amnesty and so that's the
first thing is there's not consensus
amongst the veterans and Community
secondly it's important to say that this
was never really about jail time it's
never about veterans going to prison as
I say the fix is already there for
within the government's power to ensure
that no veteran ever goes to jail what
this was about was ensuring that
families affected by violence in the
conflict had a right to a proper
investigation had a right to find out
the truth of what happened in this in
the way that the mechanespie and family
did so instead of doing that what
they've done is they've removed police
investigations no family gets their day
in court not just for prosecutions but
even in Coroner's inquest or civil
actions it's taken away all of those
rights that families had and then
replacing it with a disc commission
which does not have the legal taste to
deliver the truth that families have a
right to and indeed deserve so it was
never really about
um veterans going to prisoners if I'm
totally honest it was about getting good
headlines in the right-wing English
media in the Daily Telegraph Daily
Express and Daily Mail and that's what
it was always about it was never
actually by trying to address Legacy
and obviously the government here would
say that wasn't the case but what's your
prediction now for this bill will it go
through and what will it look like if it
does I mean it's getting a rough time in
the Lords but you can see that I mean
whether or not that rough time in the
Lords and whether or not all of the
international pressure you may have seen
they've also have significant pressure
from the United States as well it's from
Europe and from the U.N and from the
Irish government and from everybody on
this side of the water in Northern
Ireland so if any sensible government
that in kirstamer for example
um was in Belfast last week and I asked
him the direct question would he repeal
this legislation if he was elected and
he said he would so a sensible there is
a sensible route forward for the
government to pause this bill and to say
okay we had an agreement we were about
to introduce legislation previously
let's just pretend the last two years of
Reckless disregard for the rule of law
didn't happen and let's get back to a
more realistic style of government that
isn't just about getting headlines in
the right-wing press
okay well um Professor Kieran McAvoy
very interesting to get your take on it
thanks very much indeed thank you
take a look now what the weather's up to
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days look mainly fine
with daytime temperatures mostly around
average it's a largely dry and frosty
start with some freezing fog patches in
the west especially for Ireland and
Northern Ireland that fog will be slow
to lift during the morning with travel
disruption possible but there'll be
sunny spells elsewhere and it'll stay
mainly dry but the odd shower will
affect England's East Coast temperatures
will be like yesterday's but the chilly
wind will become confined to the
southeast
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up at the top of the hour we'll
have the latest ahead of the
Chancellor's upcoming speech to boost
economic growth we'll get the view from
labor that's next
[Music]